hey everybody welcome back to the
GameSpot stage at e3 on day one proper
of the conference I'm cam Robinson and I
have another game for you this now our
first fighting game of the day and it's
guilty gear exerts is that right if I
pronounced that right brilliant we've
got three M got three lovely people here
to talk about and let me sure I get this
right so we got jr. nabo and IX okay
that's okay I was so close thanks so
much for joining us on the guess what
stage guys really excited to have you
here so for people who have never heard
of the Guilty Gear series tell me tell
us all a bit about what's all about
what's the world like and what's I'm a
fighting game is anime toka manga -
koneko sorry ta ma su u ii a octo game
adicted ahmo's renato Yoda touch I got a
second
to get that aspect and turn it into a
fighting game okay great now I think
we've got some em some gameplay to have
a look at as well so let's let's have a
look about now and then maybe I'll ask
you a few questions about it about it as
it goes but I'm alright thinking this is
the the first Guilty Gear game you've
had on a console for a while is that
right hi I see you putting this in there
David okay so tell me about what we're
looking at here that top can you talk me
through the gameplay
okay don't model the model very much the
game is a ton over there there are no
character no studio jorgens to the sign
no animation in optimus-sir oh no symbol
on or Sweden or the other times GG
that's craziness so these are all based
off of the arcade mode and they have
each stories for each of the characters
and these are all using 3d real-time
animation okay so who which character
are we following here just now then
character who know game decision
connoisseur about the guy - oh really I
looked at naming the naming convention
that's great so bad guy sensei go he
sounds like a lovely guy a newsie
fighting who's this other person alive
on okay his name is Kai please he's his
rival in the game
okay so tell us a bit about the combat
so if you never play it guilty gear
before what kind of other fighting games
is similar to so is it like is it kind
of really hardcore and like Street
Fighter s combat or is this wing
football casual tell me about war game
Aquino statistic conditioning a man
under scanner war but still up there and
all system what is no do you though it
has been 50 years since guilty gear has
been created and it used to be a game
pretty for the court gamer and for the
past 15 years they've been you know
bettering the system but for this game
they wanted to sort of focus on new
players as well so they made the overall
system simple however giving the players
freedom with their gameplay as well okay
excellent
so em tell me a bit about the the world
of guilty gear for people who aren't
familiar with it what's the what's the
setting why like what's the the
backstory basically like it was Kashia
TGO sake icon I took the collage to go
to their Christmas Eve is the casino I
own a desk a little more and a shaker
are they an only happen in Chicago media
you know how I see this so the story
it's sort of hard to explain in just
like one word but this is of this
current world it's 200 years after what
we know we live today so whatever on all
gein gein Maui macaca cool stay there
mom aho oh yeah Mon okay
each TV on the second today so the
humans are using magic as part of
science and that's what they're using to
fight with one another okay right now
I'm right thinking the game is already
out in arcades in Japan is that right so
you have you been using that as a way of
testing it can be the final testing
before it comes to console out the test
of us there it is spirit to your control
or you Moscow yeah yeah do you know why
our Kido machine their irony a data
model their original Tokyo dinner by RK
dos canais so guilty air is has gained a
lot of popularity through the arcade
scene so to be able to play completely
stress-free is at the arcade so no
Cocteau game at there no are you chica
dinner gosh she's UNITA Gina Ruben unity
mascara peppery to touching a DC motor
for today June Cydia not gonna dismantle
anon de carava
arcade mighty man former grandeur on
what that's it so the fighting game in
general is one framing is very important
so if you play online there's some
limitation when you play so it's sort of
lacks in genuine
aspect so their home ground is up the
arcade okay it really well I'm Oh
obviously I as I've been saying I don't
know that much about guilty gear but I
know a lot of our fans - so guys if
you're watching you've got a I'm sure
you've got even better questions I do so
please throw some questions in the chat
and we'll ask these guys right now
and so yeah do that and we'll move on to
snow but we've got the gameplay running
again because I've got a few more so I
wanted to ask you just a bit more about
I'm in the combat so and also when
actually one of things I really know us
for am I watching a lot of the stuff you
put about the game so far is it's got
this really like heavy metal
which is that like sewing you guys are
really passionate about like you all big
male fans all right so we've got a
question from the chat and where is it
user spirit wave says will there be more
characters for the console that we have
currently on arcade eventually nanika
static state oh my mascara again don't
get add to this we would like to
eventually do something but currently
okay Big C okay so hopefully eventually
we might see some more but it's a secret
to start brilliant well guys I think I
saw we got time for the mode but thank
you so much for coming on stage and for
showing off this beautiful gameplay and
talking with us it's been a pleasure to
me all three of you so off you go enjoy
the rest three three just if you can let
let us all know if you haven't if you're
not living in Japan and you don't live
next to an arcade when can the rest of
the world to get their hands on guilty
gear part of me the release date will be
sometime during the holiday season so
they do the holiday season this year
2014 Oh brilliant so no long to wait
wonderful well guys thanks again